Sometimes you set out walking briskly on the path to disaster, without even suspecting. Scott was 23, and he saw an ad in the paper looking for a German interpreter. He'd majored in German in college, lived for a year in Germany, speaking German. What could go wrong? The job was with the Detroit Visitor Information Bureau. And his first assignment was a bunch of tourists who were going to the Ford Wixom plant. He met them early, at the hotel.
有时你会不经意地走上一条通往灾难的道路，甚至毫无察觉。斯科特当时23岁，他在报纸上看到一则招聘德语口译员的广告。他在大学主修德语，曾在德国生活过一年，能说德语。能出什么岔子呢？这份工作是为底特律游客信息局服务的。他的第一个任务是接待一群要去福特威克森工厂参观的游客。他提前在酒店和他们见了面。
They seized upon me immediately and started asking me questions. And that's when I realized that I spoke Hochdeutsch or standard German, which is what you learn in school. And they spoke Austrian, which sounds completely different. And so I really couldn't understand them.
他们立刻围住我，开始向我提问。就在那时，我意识到我只会说高地德语或标准德语，也就是学校里教的那种。而他们说的是奥地利方言，听起来完全不同。所以我真的听不懂他们在说什么。
But no time to worry about that. In minutes they're all put onto buses and off to the Ford plant.
但没时间担心这个了。几分钟后，他们都被送上了大巴，前往福特工厂。
And I knew what was going to happen. It was gradually taking shape. But we went in and there was a conference room. A man from Ford was in there with his presentation ready to go. And he said, "So where's the interpreter?" And all the Austrians gestured at me. And he said, "Good. Shall we begin." So the man starts talking all this automobile industry jargon, sort of welcome to the Ford Wixom plant. I'd like to start by explaining how a catalytic converter is implanted on our power train which moves at an estimated 1.5 meters every 10 seconds, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then he turned to me. And I just sort of stammered, "Dies ist eine auto Fabrik." This is an auto factory.
我预感到了会发生什么，情况正逐渐变得棘手。我们进去后，里面有个会议室。福特的一位先生已经在那里准备好演示文稿了。他说：“翻译在哪儿？”所有的奥地利人都指着我。他说：“很好，我们可以开始了吗。”于是那个人开始滔滔不绝地讲起汽车工业术语，什么欢迎来到福特威克森工厂，我想先解释一下催化转换器是如何植入我们动力系统的，动力系统每10秒移动约1.5米等等，巴拉巴拉一大堆。然后他转向我。我只是结结巴巴地说：“Dies ist eine auto Fabrik。” 这是一家汽车工厂。
It was somewhere around this point that Scott realized this was no idle group of Austrian tourists. These were people from the Austrian car industry. And somehow they had picked as their interpreter the one guy in Detroit who knew absolutely nothing about cars. So not only did Scott not know the German words for what they were talking about, he didn't know the English words.
就在这时，斯科特意识到这不是一群普通的奥地利游客。他们是奥地利汽车行业的人。而他们不知为何挑中了底特律唯一一个对汽车一窍不通的人作为翻译。所以斯科特不仅不知道他们讨论的内容的德语词汇，甚至连英语词汇都不知道。
So I'm just standing there stammering idiotically. And they were all looking at me politely. And so it was a total free-fall, like if you just threw someone out on an opera stage and said sing opera.
我只是像个白痴一样站在那里结巴。他们都礼貌地看着我。那真是一场彻底的崩溃，就像你把一个人扔到歌剧舞台上，让他唱歌剧一样。
And let me just ask you like if it were a simple sentence like, our conveyor belt operates at three miles an hour, can you even say that in German?
让我问你一下，如果是一句简单的句子，比如我们的传送带运行速度是每小时三英里，你能用德语说出来吗？
No.
不能。
One of the Austrian women stepped forward, and she tried to takeover the translating. What Scott did would seem like the only reasonable thing at the time. He excused himself to go to the bathroom, snuck outside, found a telephone, called a friend to come get him, and he never looked back.
一位奥地利女士走上前，试图接手翻译工作。斯科特当时能做的唯一合理的事就是借口上厕所，溜到外面，找了一部电话，叫朋友来接他，从此再也没有回头。
He felt a little ashamed. But mostly he felt relieved.
他感到有点羞愧。但更多的是如释重负。
It was a good feeling.
那是一种很好的感觉。
And can you say like-- people say a lot of about you're in a kind of a sink or swim situation and how gratifying it is to actually overcome all obstacles and to actually swim. But what you're describing, nobody really talks about how great it can be just to totally embrace utter and complete failure.
你能说一下吗——人们常说你在一种要么成要么败的境地中，克服所有障碍并最终成功是多么令人欣慰。但你所描述的，没人真正谈论过彻底拥抱彻底的失败是一件多么伟大的事情。
Well, I started to sink in that conference room. And so I just got out of the water and ran.
嗯，我在那个会议室里开始往下沉了。所以我只是从水里爬出来，然后跑了。
Which brings to the conflict at the heart of today's program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, Sink or Swim. We have three stories of people who get thrown in over their head. In one of our acts we have a guy who is not a doctor who starts doing something that even he admits only a doctor should be doing. In another, the entire world decides that a teenager is something that he feels that he is not. And Jonathan Goldstein brings us the story of the first global sink-or-swim. I'm talking of course about the story of Noah's ark. Stay with us.
这就引出了今天节目的核心冲突。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天节目的主题是“成败在此一举”。我们有三个关于人们陷入困境的故事。在其中一段中，我们有一位不是医生的人开始做他自己都承认只有医生才能做的事情。在另一段中，全世界都认定一个少年是他自己并不认可的那种人。而乔纳森·戈德斯坦为我们带来了第一个全球性的成败故事。我当然是在谈论诺亚方舟的故事。请继续收听。
Act One. Mr. Central High.
第一幕。中央高中的先生。
This is the story of somebody who gets in over his head, gets into water so deep that it is actually hard for him to make it, all by accident. He never intended for it to happen this way. Susan Drury tells the story.
这是一个关于某人陷入困境，掉进深水里以至于难以自拔的故事，一切都是意外。他从未想过会这样。苏珊·德鲁里讲述了这个故事。
There's a famous photograph you may have seen. It's a photo of Bill Clinton as a teenager. He's standing in the Rose Garden, shaking the hand of then President John F. Kennedy. Clinton was in Washington, DC, because he'd been elected governor of Boys State in Arkansas in 1963. Boys State is a mock government program held in most states.
有一张著名的照片你可能见过。那是比尔·克林顿少年时的照片。他站在玫瑰园里，与时任总统约翰·F·肯尼迪握手。克林顿在华盛顿特区，是因为他在1963年当选为阿肯色州“男生州”的州长。“男生州”是大多数州举办的一种模拟政府项目。
And then there's another less famous picture. This time Clinton is President. It's 1998. And he's shaking hands with a teenager named Chauncey Julius, who had been elected governor of Boys State in Tennessee. And if you look closely, you'll notice that Chauncey is giving Clinton a confident two-handed handshake, the kind that Clinton was known for, like Chauncey might be the one in charge.
还有另一张不太出名的照片。这次克林顿是总统。那是1998年。他正与一位名叫昌西·朱利叶斯的少年握手，他当选为田纳西州“男生州”的州长。如果你仔细观察，你会发现昌西给了克林顿一个自信的双手握手，就像克林顿标志性的握手方式一样，好像昌西才是那个说了算的人。
This is a story about how Chauncey got to be in this picture and what happened after, none of which he expected. The story starts when Chauncey's in ninth grade. He lives in Columbia, Tennessee, in a rough part of town. His mom has a good factory job at the Saturn plant. But his dad is addicted to crack and is blowing all the family's money. Chauncey is selling drugs and skipping school. He is the picture of a kid going nowhere. But one day, he decides he wants something different.
这是一个关于昌西如何出现在这张照片里以及后来发生了什么的故事，这一切他都没预料到。故事始于昌西九年级的时候。他住在田纳西州的哥伦比亚市，那里是镇上治安较差的地区。他的母亲在土星工厂有一份不错的工作。但他父亲沉迷于快克毒品，挥霍了家里所有的钱。昌西当时在卖毒品，经常逃学。他就是那个一事无成的孩子的写照。但有一天，他决定想要点不一样的生活。
I remember the day that I stopped selling drugs. There had been a couple raids in the area. Police, and having to hop out of windows and run away so I wouldn't get caught. It was the next day after one of those raids. And I was sitting on the porch. And I remember it was around this time. It was around like sundown.
我记得我停止卖毒品的那天。那片区域发生过几次突袭。警察来了，我不得不跳窗逃跑才没被抓住。那是突袭后的第二天。我坐在门廊上。我记得大约是这个时候。大概是日落时分。
And I wish I had it. But I have a little piece of paper that I still have. I wrote it in ninth grade. And on it, it has some goals. It talks about how I want to graduate from school, maybe go to graduate school.
我真希望能找到它。但我还有一张小纸片。我在九年级写的。上面写着一些目标。谈到我想从学校毕业，也许去读研究生。
And I said that I wanted to be a CEO of a major-- at that time it was a cosmetic company because Boomerang was big. The movie Boomerang. And he was like the CEO of like a cosmetic company. So I said I want to be a CEO of Revlon or something. I think that would be awesome. Just the girls and everything. They'll like me. I just wanted to be like the guy in Boomerang.
我说过我想成为一家大型——那时候是化妆品公司，因为《偷情先生》那部电影很火。那个电影的主角就像是一家化妆品公司的CEO。所以我说我想成为露华浓或者类似的公司的CEO。我觉得那会很棒。只要有那些女孩之类的。她们会喜欢我。我只是想成为电影里那个人。
And that was that. He quit selling drugs. When Chauncey came back to school, it was the start of 10th grade. He had come out of ninth grade with only half a credit, mostly because he almost never went to school. He didn't know any of the guidance counselors. But he decided he needed someone to help him. So he walked into the guidance counselor's office. There he met this woman, Mary Ann Lynn.
就是这样。他不再卖毒品了。当昌西回到学校时，正好是10年级开学。他从九年级出来时只拿到了半个学分，主要是因为他几乎从不去上学。他不认识任何指导顾问。但他决定他需要有人帮助他。于是他走进了指导顾问的办公室。在那里他遇到了玛丽·安·林恩。
He came into the guidance office and said, "Who is the best guidance counselor in this office?" And the secretary said, "Well, Ms. Lynn is the most spirited." He said, "OK, that's who I want to talk to."
他走进指导办公室说：“这里最好的指导顾问是谁？”秘书说：“林恩老师最有活力。”他说：“好，我就想和她谈谈。”
OK. Let me point something out right here. If you had only gone to school basically to sell drugs for your whole ninth grade year, would you waltz into the office and demand the very best the school had to offer? Probably not. But here's the thing everybody was about to find out about Chauncey. When he needs to turn things around, he will find what he needs to get it done. Here's Mary Ann Lynn.
好的。让我在这里指出一点。如果你九年级基本只顾着卖毒品，你会走进办公室并要求学校能提供的最好的服务吗？大概不会。但这就是大家即将发现关于昌西的事情。当他需要扭转局面时，他会找到他需要的东西来完成它。这是玛丽·安·林恩。
He wanted to know if he had any kind of chance of getting to go to college. That he could not afford anything like that. And I said, "Oh, honey. Oh, yes." I said, "We will work on our grades. There's money. We dig for money." And he says, "I know I want that. I know I may not have the background for it." But he says, "I want that."
他想知道他是否有任何上大学的机会。他负担不起任何那样的费用。我说：“噢，亲爱的。噢，有的。”我说：“我们会努力提高成绩的。有钱。我们会去挖钱。”他说：“我知道我想要那个。我知道我可能没有背景。”但他又说：“我想要那个。”
I began to go to class. I began to go to school. That was a big step. I had to remember my locker combination numbers and dust my books off. Probably one of my priorities was to graduate with my class. The thought of being left behind that was a no-go. That wasn't happening.
我开始去上课。我开始去学校。那是一大步。我不得不记住我的储物柜密码并把书本上的灰尘擦掉。我当时的首要任务之一就是和我的班级一起毕业。被抛下的想法是绝对不行的。那是绝对不会发生的。
This seems like a pretty big transition to make when you're 15 years old. But there's something about Chauncey. He wasn't an ordinary kid. He was a kid so self possessed, so good looking, and so confident that everybody noticed him and wanted to know him.
对于一个15岁的孩子来说，这似乎是一个很大的转变。但昌西身上有些与众不同的东西。他不是一个普通的孩子。他是一个非常沉稳、长相英俊且自信的孩子，以至于每个人都注意到了他并想认识他。
Even as a sophomore in high school, you wouldn't have known he was a sophomore. I mean he could come in and sit down and talk to you like he already had his degree. Now where he learned that or how he learned it at that time, I don't know. But I could see him being President or whatever. He just had a God given gift of charisma. If he had had on a neon sign, it wouldn't been any more clear.
即使是高二的时候，你也不会觉得他是个高二学生。我的意思是，他可以走进来坐下，跟你说话就像他已经拿到了学位一样。至于他在哪里学到的或者当时怎么学会的，我不知道。但我能预见他会成为总统什么的。他有一种上帝赐予的个人魅力。如果他身上贴着霓虹灯招牌，都不会更明显了。
Chauncey got to work. He took as many summer school classes as he could. He attached himself to several teachers who acted as mentors and coaches. He was in a couple plays. He was on the football team and later became captain. He became a part of a group called Elevated Young Minds. And he went with this group on a tour of black colleges. He also became increasingly involved in church. And he even got ordained as a minister. One of Chauncey's classmates told me it was like Chauncey came out of nowhere, and pretty soon he was everywhere. The kids liked him. And teachers began thinking of him as a leader, as someone who would go somewhere, someone who could do great things.
昌西开始努力了。他尽可能多地上暑期学校课程。他让自己跟随几位担任导师和教练的老师。他参加了几场戏剧演出。他加入了足球队，后来成为了队长。他成为了一个名为“提升的年轻人”的组织的一部分。他和这个组织一起参观了黑人大学。他也越来越积极地参与教会活动。他甚至被按立为牧师。昌西的一位同学告诉我，昌西就像是凭空出现的，很快他就无处不在了。孩子们喜欢他。老师们也开始把他视为领袖，视为一个会有所作为的人，一个能成就大事的人。
One day during his junior year, Chauncey was walking down the hall on the way to his English class when he saw Mary Ann Lynn in the hallway.
高三的一天，昌西在去上英语课的走廊上看到了玛丽·安·林恩。
Ms. Lynn said, "Listen to the announcements today when they come over the loudspeaker." I was like, am I in trouble? I didn't know what was going on. They caught me totally by surprise with this one. But I was listening to the announcements. And they said, Boys State delegates. My name was mentioned in there. And I was like, did they just recommend me for something? What is Boys State?
林恩老师说：“今天广播里播放通知的时候注意听。”我当时想，我惹麻烦了吗？我不知道怎么回事。他们这一下完全让我措手不及。但我还是听了通知。他们说，男生州代表。我的名字在里面提到了。我当时想，他们刚刚推荐了我去参加什么活动吗？什么是男生州？
Boys State is a big deal. Being chosen as a delegate means that the teachers at your high school think you're among most promising, the most impressive boys in the school. The program takes place over a week at a college campus. And the whole thing is geared around mock elections. Hundreds of boys representing every high school in the state are divided into towns, counties, that sort of thing. And the whole week is filled with campaigns for various offices, from sanitation chief to mayor to governor.
“男生州”是个大活动。被选为代表意味着你们高中的老师认为你是学校里最有前途、最令人印象深刻的男生之一。这个项目在大学校园里进行为期一周。整个活动都围绕着模拟选举。代表州内每一所高中的数百名男生被分成城镇、县等等。整个一周都充满了竞选各种职位的活动，从卫生主管到市长，再到州长。
So Chauncey went at the end of his junior year. He knew it was an honor, but it didn't feel like that big of a deal to him at the time. Mostly it just seemed like it would be fun. Like a long field trip where he would get to hang out in this little school.
所以昌西在高三结束时去了。他知道这是一种荣誉，但当时他觉得这没什么大不了的。大多数情况下，这看起来就像会很有趣。就像一个长途实地考察，他可以去那个小学校里玩。
But Chauncey felt different once he got to Boys State. He was surrounded by all these boys, all of whom were smart and motivated and outgoing. And even though he hadn't planned on it, Chauncey decided he would just go for it and run for governor, the highest office. It was almost like he couldn't help himself. He announced his candidacy in front of hundreds of boys in a huge auditorium.
但昌西到了“男生州”后感觉就不一样了。他被所有这些男生包围着，他们都很聪明、有动力、外向。尽管他没打算过，但昌西决定他要全力以赴竞选州长，这是最高职位。就好像他无法克制自己一样。他在一个巨大的礼堂里，在数百名男生面前宣布了他的候选资格。
Everyone who was running for governor is in this room. People just yelling out, hey vote for me. Side conversations and everything. People holding up banners. And people got their cronies and their little goons saying, vote for my best friend here. You hear all that added. The other people that was running, they come with all these supplies. Markers. They got construction paper, poster boards. Everything. They came prepped. And I had this little dingy t-shirt that I held up that I wrote with probably a Expo dry erase marker. I wrote, Julius for Governor. And I held the shirt up. And I remember the response. Boo, whatever. Put that shirt down. Ain't nobody voting for you. And immediately, something clicked on the inside. Don't tell me that you're not going to vote for me. Don't tell me that I can't do nothing. You're not going to tell me that I'm not going to win.
每个竞选州长的人都在这个房间里。人们大喊着，嘿，投我一票。各种私下谈话。人们举着横幅。人们带着他们的亲信和随从说，投给我这位好朋友。你听到了所有这些嘈杂声。其他候选人，他们带来了所有这些物资。马克笔。他们有手工纸、海报板。什么都有。他们是有备而来的。而我只有一件破旧的T恤，我用可能是Expo干擦马克笔写着。我写着，朱利叶斯选州长。我举起那件衬衫。我记得当时的回应。嘘声，什么的。把那衬衫放下。没人会投给你。那一刻，内心深处有什么东西被触动了。别告诉我你们不会投给我。别告诉我我什么都做不了。你休想告诉我我不会赢。
Chauncey gave a terrific speech and beat out 11 other guys to become the nominee of his party. And as he headed into the general election, people flocked to his campaign.
昌西发表了一场精彩的演讲，击败了其他11个人，成为他所在政党的提名人。当他进入大选时，人们涌向他的竞选活动。
People were just doing crazy stuff like hanging out stuff from their room windows. And across the whole window, they'd hang out a banner that says, "Vote for Julius" or vote for-- And I'm just like, wow, I didn't ask the guy to do that.
人们开始做一些疯狂的事情，比如从房间窗户挂出东西。在整个窗户上挂出一道横幅，写着“投朱利叶斯一票”或者……我当时就想，哇，我没让那个人这么做啊。
For the first time Chauncey saw all these people, not just teachers but kids now, pulling for him, doing things for him, just because he was him. He was shocked by it and overwhelmed. I mean what does it say about you when a guy you don't even know shaves your name into his hair?
昌西第一次看到所有这些人，不仅仅是老师，现在还有孩子们，在支持他，为他做事情，仅仅因为他是他。他对此感到震惊，不知所措。我的意思是，当一个你甚至都不认识的人把你名字刻在头发里时，这说明了什么？
On the day of the election for governor, the other candidates nervously stood at the podium and read their speeches. But Chauncey took to the stage as if he had done it a hundred times before. By this time he'd already preached at his church. And he was really interested in leadership. He'd read all sorts of books on it. He grabbed the mike and walked the stage like a motivational speaker. He was a natural. And he had the audience, hundreds of 17-year-old boys, captivated.
州长选举那天，其他候选人紧张地站在讲台上读着他们的演讲稿。但昌西走上台时，就像他以前做过一百次一样。到那时，他已经在他的教会布道过了。他对领导力非常感兴趣。他读过各种关于这方面的书。他抓起麦克风，在舞台上走动，就像一个励志演讲家。他很有天赋。他让台下的数百名17岁男孩深深着迷。
It was like it was in slow motion. I got up, and I just began to just go for it. Clapping, standing-O. Everything. It was just like a rush, an adrenalin rush. And where it was so much where I was almost about to pass out because the rush was so great. And it was like a drug. It was-- Wow!
就像是慢动作一样。我站起来，然后就完全投入了。鼓掌、全体起立。所有的一切。这就像一种快感，肾上腺素的爆发。程度之大，我差点晕倒，因为那快感太强烈了。这就像一种毒品。那是——哇！
He won in a landslide.
他以压倒性优势获胜。
Chauncey came back home after being elected governor at Boys State. But his position in his hometown had changed. His win was important not just for him, but for lots of people in his town for lots of reasons. Colombia's just 30,000 people. And nobody from Colombia had ever been elected governor of Boys State. And here was Chauncey, the black kid from a tough neighborhood. The kid who turned his life around, bringing home the honor. It became a very big deal.
昌西在“男生州”当选州长后回到家。但他在家乡的地位已经改变了。他的胜利不仅对他个人很重要，而且因为各种原因对镇上的许多人也很重要。哥伦比亚只有3万人。而且哥伦比亚从来没有人当选过“男生州”的州长。而现在昌西，这个来自贫困社区的黑人孩子。这个改变了人生的孩子，把这份荣誉带回家了。这成了一件大事。
The word is spreading. The word is spreading, even in my neighborhood. Even the people that's my friends that was out there still selling drugs. What you doing man? I saw you in the Daily Herald. You the governor? You won. You the governor now? They was like man, congratulations.
消息在传开。消息在传开，即使是在我的社区。即使是我的那些朋友，那些还在外面卖毒品的人。老兄，你在干嘛？我在《每日先驱报》看到你了。你是州长？你赢了。你现在是州长了？他们说，老兄，恭喜。
The Chamber of Commerce threw him a big party and gave him a plaque. The County Commission named June 19th, Chauncey Julius Day. Chauncey spoke to the local American Legion, the Kiwanis Club, the Lions Club. He is a story and a guy people could not get enough of.
商会为他举办了一个盛大的派对，并颁发了一块牌匾。县委员会将6月19日命名为“昌西·朱利叶斯日”。昌西向当地的美国退伍军人协会、基瓦尼俱乐部、狮子俱乐部发表了演讲。他是一个人们怎么看都看不够的故事，也是一个人。
And though Chauncey had won a mock election for a mock office, he got some very real power out of it at his own school. Administrators asked him to help pick the new principal. And the student government appointed him to a special office created just for him. And when all the seniors voted on the superlatives-- you know, most likely to succeed, most popular, those sorts of things-- Chauncey won so many awards that the administrators had to call him into the office and tell him to pick just two, so other people could have some. He chose Mr. Central High School and Mr. Football.
尽管昌西赢得的是模拟职位和模拟选举，但他确实从中获得了一些非常现实的权力，在他的学校里。管理人员让他帮忙挑选新校长。学生会任命他担任一个专为他设立的特殊职位。当所有高年级学生投票选出“最可能成功”、“最受欢迎”之类的奖项时，昌西赢得了太多的奖项，以至于管理人员不得不把他叫到办公室，告诉他只能选两个，好让其他人也能拿一些。他选择了“中央高中先生”和“橄榄球先生”。
I got away with a whole lot more. Had a little bit of influence. Had a little bit of power. Had some connects. And I can get out of some things a little bit easier, after all I did. I was on the panel to decide who was going to be the next principal. So there was some arrogance there, a little bit. I knew some people. Didn't have to go to class as much because some of the teachers I had, had a hand in helping me go to Boys State. So it's like, it's Chauncey, he all right.
我摆平的事情多了去了。有了一点影响力。有了一点权力。有一些人脉。我可以在做了某些事之后更容易地脱身。我是挑选下一任校长的委员会成员。所以那里确实有一些傲慢，有一点点。我认识一些人。不必那么多去上课，因为我的一些老师在帮我参加“男生州”方面出过力。所以就好像是，那是昌西，他没问题。
But none of the success changed his home life, which was still as unpredictable and crazy as ever. Chauncey's mom, Deborah Julius, told me they lived in a house where you can go to the closet it to get your coat and find that Chauncey's dad had sold it for drugs. She never felt like they belonged in the circles Chauncey was now moving in. Here's Deborah.
但这些成功都没有改变他的家庭生活，它依然像以前一样不可预测和疯狂。昌西的母亲黛博拉·朱利叶斯告诉我，他们住的房子里，你到壁橱里拿大衣时会发现昌西的父亲已经把它卖掉换毒品了。她从没觉得他们属于昌西现在身处的圈子。这是黛博拉。
Part of me kind of, sort of wanted to say why did you do this? Don't get me wrong. I was happy. I was elated. What was happening to Chauncey was great, under any other circumstances, like if he had a dad that was prominent or if he had a dad that even had a good job and was just an ordinary Joe. If we were just a normal family and a functional family.
我内心深处有时会想问你为什么这么做？别误解我。我很开心。我欣喜若狂。发生在昌西身上的一切都很棒，在任何其他情况下，比如如果他有个显赫的父亲，或者他父亲有个好工作，只是一个普通人。如果我们只是一个正常的、功能正常的家庭。
Did you ever think they had it wrong?
你有没有想过他们搞错了？
Every day. Every day I knew they had it wrong. I was same person that brought piles of weed past your doors when I was in ninth grade. Am I really a success? This is just high school, people. We're about to graduate. Not only that, but I'm going through hell in my home. So my grades aren't all that good. I'm still struggling at Algebra II. Will I pass Algebra II? I have a lot of flaws. Ya'll sure you got the right person?
每天。每天我都知道他们搞错了。我就是九年级时把一大堆大麻带到你们门外的那个人。我真的是个成功人士吗？这只是高中，各位。我们马上就要毕业了。不仅如此，我在家里还经历着地狱。所以我的成绩并没有那么好。我还在代数II上挣扎。我会通过代数II吗？我有很多缺陷。你们确定找对人了吗？
Chauncey was facing a whole community, everybody with these huge expectations. And at some point of his senior year, he couldn't do it anymore. He just wanted to disappear. Here's Mary Ann Lynn.
昌西正面对着整个社区，每个人都对他抱有巨大的期望。在高三的某个时刻，他再也承受不住了。他只想消失。这是玛丽·安·林恩。
We put him in a place where if he came down a notch, he would feel like he failed. I'm not sure we did the right thing on some of that. Then I feel like what happened to him and what happens to anybody in that situation is hey, I do have to be great. They've told me I'm great. I've got to be perfect. And there were still some struggles with some academics. And the background, he just didn't have it. So he had so much pressure on him to be great.
我们把他放在了一个如果他状态下滑就会感到失败的位置。我不确定我们在这方面做得对不对。我觉得发生在他身上的事，以及任何处于那种境地的人所经历的，就是“嘿，我必须变得伟大”。他们告诉我我很伟大。我必须变得完美。学业上仍然存在一些挣扎。还有背景，他就是没有那个条件。所以他承受着巨大的压力要变得伟大。
I felt the pressure to perform, to perform in academics. The pressure for football. I was a senior. I was a captain. The pressure from friends, where you don't hang out with us as much as you used to because I'm really involved in school activities. And the fact that I'm trying to graduate. Prior to no one knowing my name, I didn't have these pressures.
我感受到了表现的压力，在学业上表现。橄榄球的压力。我是高年级学生。我是队长。朋友们的压力，他们说你不像以前那样和我们混了，因为我真的很忙于学校活动。还有我试图毕业的事实。在没人知道我的名字之前，我没有这些压力。
If he could just make it to graduation and pass all his classes, he'd have a full scholarship at Tennessee Tech, thanks to his win at Boys State. The scholarship was Chauncey's dream. But after three years of trying to play catch-up up with the rest of his class, at the end of his senior year he was still one credit short.
如果他能坚持到毕业并通过所有课程，多亏了他在“男生州”的获胜，他将获得田纳西理工大学的全额奖学金。那份奖学金是昌西的梦想。但在尝试追赶班级进度三年后，在高三结束时，他还是差一个学分。
And I didn't graduate with a diploma. It hurt. Embarrassing, because I was the poster boy. Didn't finish in what really mattered. I wanted that more than anything, to graduate.
我没能拿到毕业证书。很受伤。很尴尬，因为我是那个海报男孩。没有完成真正重要的事情。我想要那个超过一切，毕业。
Here's Mary Ann Lynn.
这是玛丽·安·林恩。
We kind of set him up for failure. Everything went wonderful. And then right before he went to college, it was like throwing mud in his face. So he went down. His feelings about school, about himself, and everything. How did I be so great and then all at once everything go wrong?
我们算是让他走向了失败。一切都进行得那么好。然后就在他上大学前，就像往他脸上扔泥巴。所以他跌落谷底。他对自己、对学校的感受，一切。我怎么会那么伟大，然后突然之间一切都变糟了？
Chauncey's successes had been very public. But his failure was pretty private. He was allowed to walk in his school's graduation ceremony. And hardly anybody even knew he didn't really graduate.
昌西的成功非常公开。但他的失败相当私密。他被允许参加学校的毕业典礼。几乎没人知道他其实没毕业。
The next fall, Chauncey got another chance. He showed up at college, took the GED test that weekend, and was instantly admitted. But within a couple of weeks, he stopped going to class. College was harder than he thought. And he felt like he had lost his momentum. He spent his time hanging out and partying. He basically fell off the map, like he had in ninth grade.
第二年秋天，昌西又得到了一个机会。他去上大学，那个周末参加了同等学力考试，并立即被录取。但在几周内，他就不去上课了。大学比他想象的要难。他觉得失去了动力。他把时间花在闲逛和聚会上。他基本上从地图上消失了，就像九年级那样。
And I had like a lot of support there. I just never used it. I thought that when you go to college everything you need to succeed, you already had to possess. And I didn't. And I felt that I was a fraud. I felt that I had let people down. I was like OK, I don't have what it takes.
我在那里确实有很多支持。我只是从没用过它。我以为当你上大学时，你必须已经拥有成功所需的一切。但我没有。我觉得我是一个骗子。我觉得我让人们失望了。我就想，好吧，我不具备成功的条件。
By the end of freshman year, he had lost his scholarship and was kicked out. He came back to Columbia. He half-heartedly took some classes at the local community college. He worked in a factory and at Long John Silver. Everyone in his hometown, the bankers, the preachers, the drug dealers, knew who he was and had thought he was heading somewhere. He went from possibly the most promising kid in town to just another kid with a GED and no plans for the future. Chauncey decided joining the army would solve his problems. He went down to the recruiter's office and signed up.
大一结束时，他失去了奖学金，被开除了。他回到哥伦比亚。他心不在焉地在当地社区学院选了几门课。他在工厂和Long John Silver餐厅打工。家乡的所有人，银行家、牧师、毒贩，都知道他是谁，并认为他会有一番作为。他从镇上最有前途的孩子变成了另一个只有同等学力证书、对未来毫无计划的孩子。昌西决定参军会解决他的问题。他去了招募办公室报了名。
Recruiters would love a person like this. I mean they didn't have to work hard at all. My recruiter was so laid back because he knew I was so-- He didn't have to work at all. Whatever he put in front of me, I did. I was like, whatever you want. You don't even have to drive me to Nashville to the medical station, I will run from Colombia. That's like 45 miles. And I was like, I will go. Whatever you need for me to do, whatever it takes for me to get away from here, and for me not to face the embarrassment of failing to this community, to my high school, to whatever it takes for me where you're going to enable me to run. I'm going to do it. Ten days later from the time I walked into that office, I was gone.
招募人员会喜欢这样的人。我的意思是他们根本不需要费劲。我的招募员非常悠闲，因为他知道我非常……他根本不需要做任何工作。无论他放在我面前什么，我都照做。我就想，无论你想要什么。你甚至不需要开车送我到纳什维尔的医疗站，我会从哥伦比亚跑过去。那是大约45英里。我当时就想，我会去的。无论你需要我做什么，无论我需要付出什么代价才能离开这里，为了不面对辜负这个社区、我的高中的尴尬，为了能让我逃跑的任何代价。我都会做。从我走进那个办公室那天起，十天后，我就走了。
And in the army, the trend that had started years earlier came back. His superiors saw in him something. Leadership, he says. Determination. But there was one difference in the army. Nobody cared about his potential, about what he might do. They only cared about what he actually did.
在军队里，多年前开始的趋势又回来了。他的上级在他身上看到了东西。领导力，他说。决心。但在军队里有一个区别。没人关心他的潜力，关于他将来可能做什么。他们只关心他实际做了什么。
Chauncey got sent to Iraq. And then he came back, got married, and reenlisted for another tour. In all, he spent six years in the Army. And he just got out. Things haven't turned out the way he thought, but they are turning out. For the first time in many years, he feels like he can return home with no shame.
昌西被派往伊拉克。然后他回来了，结婚了，又重新服役了另一轮任务。总共，他在军队待了六年。他刚刚退役。事情并没有按照他想的那样发展，但它们正在发展。多年来第一次，他觉得可以回家而不用感到羞耻。
And I talked to a lot of my friends. And they say, Chaunce, I thought you'd be on TV by now. Like honestly, like we expected to see you on CNN. Like, what are you doing? They always want to know like what I'm doing. And I'm just, I was in the military for a while. I was in school for a while. And I went into the military. And went to Iraq twice. And I'm back in school.
我和我的很多朋友谈过。他们说，昌西，我以为你应该已经上电视了。老实说，我们期待在CNN上看到你。你在做什么？他们总是想知道我在做什么。我只是说，我参军了一段时间。我上了一段时间学。然后我加入了军队。去了伊拉克两次。我现在又回到学校了。
But I'm running my race. I had to learn that. I had to really learn that. And I think what people saw in me is happening right now. What they saw and what they saw can happen possibly is happening right now in my life.
但我正在跑我自己的赛道。我必须学到这一点。我必须真正学到这一点。我认为人们在我身上看到的东西现在正在发生。他们所看到的，以及他们认为可能发生的，现在正在我的生活中发生。
Chauncey's counselor, Mary Ann Lynn, has thought a lot about why it took till now for Chauncey to come into his own, about why things went so wrong at the end of high school for him. She's got a gift for finding kids who are about to fall through the cracks. And she makes it her business to try to help them. And when she looks at what happened to Chauncey, she thinks the adults in his life just got carried away.
昌西的辅导员玛丽·安·林恩思考了很多关于为什么昌西直到现在才真正成熟起来，为什么高中结束时事情会变得那么糟。她有一种天赋，能发现那些即将掉进深渊的孩子。她以此为己任去帮助他们。当她审视昌西身上发生的事情时，她认为他生命中的大人们只是太冲动了。
Probably the cruel thing-- Sometimes I've blamed myself with, OK, did I push him too hard and put him into a position that was so hard to survive? But we took him from just being a kid in school and kind of made him famous. And then he had all this stuff thrown at him. And I don't think we realized what we were pushing him into.
也许最残酷的事情是——有时我责怪自己，是不是我太逼他了，把他放到了一个很难生存的位置？但我们把他从一个只是在校读书的孩子变成了某种程度上的名人。然后他面临了所有这些施加在他身上的东西。我不认为我们意识到我们在把他推向何处。
Chauncey just started school at Kansas State University near Fort Riley, where he was based in the Army. Within the first three weeks of school, one of his deans told him they hadn't seen a student of his stature in 25 years. The dean predicted that Chauncey would take the school by storm.
昌西刚在堪萨斯州立大学入学，离他服役的赖利堡很近。开学不到三周，一位院长告诉他，他们25年来没见过像他这样地位的学生。院长预言昌西会以雷霆之势征服这所学校。
Susan Drury, in Nashville.
苏珊·德鲁里，在纳什维尔。
Coming up, a former heroin addict gets into a situation where he has to invent for himself, on his own, the rules and procedures of being a doctor. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一位前海洛因瘾君子陷入了一个必须自己发明医生规则和程序的境地。这将在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台节目继续一分钟后播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Sink or Swim. We have stories of people who put themselves into situations that they are completely unprepared for. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two. I'm Not A Doctor But I Play One At The Holiday Inn.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种关于该主题的故事。今天的节目是“成败在此一举”。我们有关于人们将自己置于完全没有准备好的境地中的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕。我不是医生，但我在假日酒店扮演过。
Back in the '60s, a heavy drug user, a hippie, named Howard Lotsof, tried a powerful hallucinogen named ibogaine. Lotsof apparently had one of the most intense drug experiences of his life. And when it was done, the odd thing was he had absolutely no desire to ever use drugs again. Just wasn't interested. He stayed clean. And years later, he decided that ibogaine should be used to cure drug addicts. And so he tested and got patents for several different dosages of ibogaine. But for a variety of reasons it never got picked up by any of your mainstream drug companies.
回到60年代，一位名叫霍华德·洛特索夫的重度吸毒者、嬉皮士，尝试了一种强力致幻剂伊博格碱。洛特索夫显然经历了生命中最强烈的毒品体验之一。当它结束时，奇怪的是他完全没有再吸毒的欲望了。只是不感兴趣。他戒掉了。几年后，他认为伊博格碱应该被用来治疗瘾君子。于是他测试并获得了几种不同剂量伊博格碱的专利。但由于各种原因，它从未被任何主流制药公司采用。
But ibogaine hung around on the margins. This drug, like it's supposed to be doing the impossible, especially for heroin addicts. You take it. You go on this intense trip. And at the end of that trip, you have no withdrawal symptoms. None. Nothing. And you also have no desire to ever do heroin again. Well, this brings us to our story, which was put together by Lu Olkowski and Trey Kay. Lu narrates.
但伊博格碱一直处于边缘地带。这种药，它被认为能做不可能的事情，尤其是对海洛因瘾君子。你服下它。你开始一段强烈的幻觉之旅。而在那次旅行结束时，你没有戒断症状。完全没有。什么都没有。而且你也没有再吸食海洛因的欲望。嗯，这就引出了我们的故事，由卢·奥尔科夫斯基和特雷·凯制作。卢担任旁白。
At his worst, Dimitri was living in his parents' basement in Detroit. He had been using heroin for 27 years. His wife had died. Many of his friends had died, and he was edging towards 40. That was when it finally hit him that it was time to do something.
在最糟糕的时候，迪米特里住在底特律父母的地下室里。他使用海洛因已经27年了。他的妻子去世了。他的许多朋友也死了，他快40岁了。就在那时，他终于意识到是时候做点什么了。
In 2002, Dimitri went to Amsterdam for an experimental ibogaine treatment. It was given to him by a woman who cared for drug users our of her thatched roof farmhouse, surrounded by her five kids. Thirty hours after taking the drug, Dimitri was cured of his heroin addiction, literally cured of his 27-year-old habit. He remembers waking up at the crack of dawn three days later and experiencing a sensation that he hadn't felt in years, joy.
2002年，迪米特里去了阿姆斯特丹接受实验性伊博格碱治疗。是一位照顾吸毒者的妇女在她的茅草屋顶农舍里给他服用的，周围有她的五个孩子。服药30小时后，迪米特里的海洛因成瘾被治愈了，字面意思上治愈了他27年的习惯。他记得三天后在黎明时分醒来，体验到一种他多年未曾感受到的感觉：快乐。
I have never felt that good in my life. Didn't need heroin. I was completely exhausted. And I just kept on saying-- I said praise God, over and over and over again. And one of the little girls-- I can't remember which daughter it was. She said, "We had a black man from the Bronx, and he kept saying the same thing. Praise God and praise God."
我一生中从未感到那么好。不需要海洛因。我完全精疲力尽。我只是不停地说——我说赞美上帝，一遍又一遍。其中一个小女孩——我不记得是哪个女儿了。她说：“我们有个来自布朗克斯的黑人，他一直在说同样的话。赞美上帝，赞美上帝。”
Dimitri says a lot of people come out of ibogaine treatments feeling euphoric, almost evangelical. And Dimitri became a kind of ibogaine convert, determined to take the good news about this miracle drug that had instantly cured him, to other junkies. He knew tons of people back in the States that needed help. And as far as Dimitri was concerned, they weren't treated well by the traditional medical establishment.
迪米特里说，很多人从伊博格碱治疗中出来时感到欣快，几乎是福音派。迪米特里成了某种伊博格碱的皈依者，决心把治愈他的这种奇迹药物的好消息带给其他瘾君子。他知道在美国有成吨的人需要帮助。据迪米特里所知，他们没有得到传统医疗机构的良好对待。
I mean my girlfriend works at a hospital. She comes back and tells me these stories. I've seen it. I've been in a hospital when I was an active user and fought with doctors for friends of mine. I had a friend of mine sitting home with spinal meningitis and aspirin because they didn't believe it. And he turned out to be HIV-positive too. And I take him in a second time. And got in a big fight with this doctor who started moralizing. "God only gives you three chances." None as an MD, but he knows how many chances God gives you.
我的女朋友在医院工作。她回来告诉我这些故事。我见过。我还是活跃吸毒者的时候进过医院，为了我的朋友和医生争吵。我有个朋友患有脊髓脑膜炎，家里却只有阿司匹林，因为他们不相信。他后来发现还携带艾滋病毒。我第二次带他去。结果和那个开始进行道德说教的医生大吵一架。“上帝只给你三次机会。”他不是医学博士，但他知道上帝给人的机会有多少。
And so Dimitri decided to become an ibogaine provider himself, to save his friends just like the woman in Amsterdam had saved him. There were only two problems with this otherwise laudable goal. First of all, because ibogaine is a hallucinogen, it's illegal in the US. It's a Schedule I drug, like heroin. And if Dimitri was caught buying or selling ibogaine, he could go to prison for the rest of his life. The second problem was that by giving people ibogaine, Dimitri was basically doing the job of a doctor or nurse, without being either.
于是迪米特里决定自己成为一名伊博格碱提供者，像阿姆斯特丹那位妇女救他一样去救他的朋友。这个听起来值得称赞的目标只有两个问题。首先，因为伊博格碱是一种致幻剂，它在美国是非法的。它属于一级管制药物，像海洛因一样。如果迪米特里被抓住购买或出售伊博格碱，他可能会在监狱里度过余生。第二个问题是，通过给人们提供伊博格碱，迪米特里本质上是在做医生或护士的工作，却并非二者中的任何一个。
Dimitri was a small-time rock star, bike messenger, dishwasher. He hadn't even taken a first aid course. And ibogaine is a potentially dangerous psychotropic. So for guidance, Dimitri hooked up with other underground ibogaine providers, former junkies like Dimitri who over several decades had developed a kind of ad hoc collection of protocols about dosage and care. And the first time he gave a treatment, it went OK. But with the second guy, a drug dealer who helped Dimitri find ibogaine and who actually referred addicts to him for treatment, it didn't go so smoothly,
迪米特里曾是个小摇滚明星、自行车快递员、洗碗工。他甚至没参加过急救课程。而伊博格碱是一种潜在危险的精神药物。所以为了指导，迪米特里联系了其他地下伊博格碱提供者，像迪米特里一样的前瘾君子，他们在几十年里制定了一套关于剂量和护理的临时规程。他第一次进行治疗时，效果还可以。但第二个家伙，一个帮助迪米特里寻找伊博格碱并实际上把瘾君子转介给迪米特里治疗的毒贩，过程就不那么顺利了。
So we go through the process. He gets done with it basically. OK. This is my second treatment. And then he goes into a seizure, eyes rolling to the back of his head, foaming at the mouth, biting his tongue, a seizure. It was unbelievable. I thought he was dead, Long story short, I was freaked. And actually at that point I panicked. I didn't know what to do.
所以我们走完全程。他基本完成了。好的。这是我的第二次治疗。然后他开始癫痫发作，眼睛翻到后脑勺，口吐白沫，咬着舌头，癫痫。简直难以置信。我以为他死了，长话短说，我吓坏了。实际上在那一刻我惊慌失措。我不知道该怎么办。
This guy was going to die and what the hell am I doing? And this guy's going to die. And yeah, what business do I have to do this?
这家伙要死了，我到底在干什么？这家伙要死了。是啊，我有什么资格做这个？
Dimitri managed to get the guy to a hospital, where he eventually recovered. But this was the first time Dimitri realized exactly what he had gotten himself into. How crazy it was to be flying without a net, doing a job that put other people's lives into his hands. And this is the issue. Dimitri knows what it's like to be a junkie, to be desperate, frantic, to quit. And he believes that since he has what he thinks is a cure, despite the risk, it's his moral responsibility, his obligation really, to help.
迪米特里设法把那人送到了医院，他最终康复了。但这是迪米特里第一次意识到他到底陷入了什么境地。在没有安全网的情况下飞行，做着把别人的生命掌握在自己手中的工作是多么疯狂。这就是问题所在。迪米特里知道当瘾君子是什么感觉，那种绝望、狂乱、想要戒掉的感觉。他相信既然他手里有他认为是治愈方法的东西，尽管有风险，这不仅是他的道德责任，更是他的义务，去帮助他们。
It's terrifying, man. And especially, you spend time with these people. You get to know people. God, you don't want them to die. You don't want them to be hurt in any way.
这太可怕了，伙计。特别是，你和这些人共度时光。你了解他们。天哪，你不想让他们死。你不想让他们以任何方式受伤。
Because Dimitri doesn't want his clients to be hurt in any way, he tries to be as much like a professional clinic as a former junkie with a by-the-seat-of-your-pants operation can be. He says he's even cobbled together a set of rules, more or less through trial and error. For example, a client should be clean of drugs and alcohol for a certain amount of time before treatment. They should get EKGs if possible and liver panels. And so just like he's had to invent nearly everything else about this job, he's had to invent boundaries for himself. Boundaries that are hard to maintain with everyone.
因为迪米特里不希望他的客户以任何方式受伤，他尽力表现得像一个专业诊所，尽管他只是一个前瘾君子在草率行事。他说他甚至通过反复试验拼凑出一套规则。例如，客户在治疗前应该戒毒戒酒一段时间。他们应该尽可能进行心电图和肝功能检查。就像他必须发明这份工作的几乎所有其他东西一样，他也必须为自己发明界限。这些界限对每个人来说都很难维持。
They ring my doorbell, call me up in the night. I had a guy threatening to shoot me two weeks ago who had had a relapse. And this is like a real close guy, man. He wanted to [BLEEP] kill me.
他们按门铃，半夜给我打电话。两周前有个家伙威胁要开枪打我，他复吸了。这是一个非常亲近的人，伙计。他想 [哔] 杀了我。
Having a client threaten to shoot you probably wouldn't be accepted in the world of professional medicine. But Dimitri sees addicts differently than most people do. He loves them. I interviewed him for a total of 35 hours over seven months. And here's how he described every single addict he knows.
让客户威胁要开枪打你可能不会在专业医疗界被接受。但迪米特里看待瘾君子和大多数人不同。他爱他们。我在七个月里采访了他总共35个小时。这是他描述他认识的每一个瘾君子的方式。
He's really a god. He's a beautiful guy. He's a great guy. He's a musician. He's a writer. He's an incredibly sweet man. And he's such a great guy. He's got great taste in music. He's read some great books. He's funny. He's strange. I like him, man. I really like him.
他真的是个上帝。他是个漂亮的家伙。他是个很棒的家伙。他是音乐家。他是作家。他是个极其甜美的人。他真是个好人。他有很好的音乐品味。他读过很棒的书。他风趣。他很奇怪。我喜欢他，伙计。我真的很喜欢他。
One of the people Dimitri talks about this way, one of his clients, is Jimmy. Jimmy's middle-aged, clean cut, working class. The kind of guy you'd see working at the post office or sitting next you on a bus. He's clearly genuinely a sweet guy. But if you hang around with him long enough, you feel the dark cloud that follows him around.
迪米特里谈论的人之一，他的客户之一，是吉米。吉米中年，干净利落，工人阶级。那种你在邮局工作时或在公交车上坐在你旁边时会看到的家伙。他显然是一个真正甜美的家伙。但如果你和他待得够久，你会感觉到萦绕在他身边的阴云。
I talked to Jimmy a few days before Dimitri was going to give him an ibogaine treatment And he told me he had tried to shake heroin many times before. He'd done traditional rehab, and a whole array of alternative treatments. He even tried ibogaine once before, with another underground provider. According to Jimmy, ibogaine pretty much worked the first time around. He says after the treatment he felt no craving for heroin. The thing that made him relapse was the dark cloud, all the other problems in his life.
我在迪米特里给吉米进行伊博格碱治疗前几天和他谈过。他告诉我他以前尝试过很多次摆脱海洛因。他做过传统戒毒，还有一系列替代疗法。他甚至以前尝试过一次伊博格碱，是和另一个地下提供者。据吉米说，伊博格碱第一次基本奏效了。他说治疗后他感觉不到对海洛因的渴望。让他复吸的是那朵阴云，他生活中的所有其他问题。
Somewhere around three or four months when I started feeling a little bit lonely again. It's like, why isn't anything really happening? I mean I'm feeling all these feelings, but what's really changing in my life. I remember Eric was talking about a guy taking ibogaine. And a few months later he met a girl. He got married. So I'm like, when is this going to happen for me? And then I started getting to feel like, ahh, maybe I'm just the same old person, and there is no cure.
大概在三四个月的时候，我开始感到又有点孤独了。就像，为什么没什么真正的事情发生？我的意思是，我感觉到了所有这些感受，但我的生活中真正改变了什么？我记得埃里克当时在谈论一个人服用伊博格碱。几个月后他遇到了一个女孩。他结婚了。所以我当时想，什么时候这种事会发生在我身上？然后我开始觉得，啊，也许我还是原来的那个人，根本没有治愈方法。
Let's see where this knucklehead is.
看看这个傻瓜在哪儿。
I'm standing on a street corner in the rain in midtown Manhattan with Dimitri. It's 5:00 PM, the time Jimmy is supposed to show for his treatment. But he's late. Dimitri is not happy. Just the week before, he was waiting for a client in the exact same spot and the guy never showed. It's not unusual. The flake factor is an occupational hazard when your entire client base is heroin addicts. But it still gets to Dimitri, who's always nervous and tense before a treatment.
我和迪米特里站在曼哈顿中城下雨的街角。现在是下午5点，吉米应该来接受治疗的时间。但他迟到了。迪米特里不高兴。就在前一周，他在同一个地方等一个客户，那家伙根本没露面。这并不罕见。当你的整个客户群都是海洛因瘾君子时，不靠谱是职业危害。但这仍然会让迪米特里生气，他在治疗前总是紧张不安。
I'm getting hives, which is normal. You see. It's all over my legs and my feet. I get hives every treatment.
我正在起荨麻疹，这是正常的。你看。到处都是，在我的腿上和脚上。我每次治疗都会起荨麻疹。
Finally, three hours later-- three hours-- Jimmy arrives.
终于，三个小时后——三个小时——吉米到了。
There he is. [WHISTLES] Jimmy! Jimmy!
他在这儿。[口哨声] 吉米！吉米！
We drive up and open the car door for Jimmy.
我们开车过去，为吉米打开车门。
[BLEEP]. Get the [BLEEP] in the car.
[哔]。进 [哔] 车里来。
Sorry for putting you through a lot of crap.
很抱歉让你经历了一堆烂事。
What did you forget? That you're going to take like a [BLEEP] strong African hallucinogen today. It like slipped your mind?
你忘了什么？你今天本来要服用一种 [哔] 强力的非洲致幻剂。你忘了？
Yeah. I just crashed because I was like up all night.
是的。我只是崩溃了，因为我整晚都没睡。
Oh, OK. At least you got some sleep.
噢，好的。至少你睡了一觉。
And then Dimitri begins the underground provider equivalent of an intake survey.
然后迪米特里开始了地下提供者的入职调查。
You been hydrating yourself today?
你今天补水了吗？
Yeah, sort of.
是的，算是吧。
When's the last time you used?
你最后一次吸毒是什么时候？
Thursday.
星期四。
What time?
几点？
7:00 maybe, 8:00.
大概7点，8点。
OK. How many bags were you doing at the end?
好的。你最后一次量是多少？
It really depended on how much money I had. I tried to hold a bundle through the whole week. And I ended up doing the whole bundle of in one day. I mean I can't hold onto it. It sucks.
这真的取决于我有多少钱。我试着留一包维持整个星期。结果我一天就把一包全用完了。我的意思是，我控制不住它。真烂。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊。
As I listen to this exchange, it's hard to tell if Dimitri is getting any useful information. It's all so casual. Basically, Dimitri and Jimmy just joke around until we get to the hotel in New Jersey. A comfortable chain, where Dimitri has instructed Jimmy to book an economy suite with a small bedroom and a separate living space with cable TV. While Jimmy hangs out, Dimitri puts away some groceries and preps the room.
当我听这段对话时，很难说迪米特里是否得到了任何有用的信息。一切都太随意了。基本上，迪米特里和吉米只是在开玩笑，直到我们到了新泽西的一家酒店。一家舒适的连锁酒店，迪米特里指示吉米预订了一间经济型套房，带一个小卧室和一个带有限电视的独立起居区。当吉米待着的时候，迪米特里放好了一些杂货并准备房间。
I'm going to set up a bucket for him to puke in. I want to make the room as dark as possible. Good thing we're starting at night.
我要给他准备一个桶让他呕吐。我想让房间尽可能暗。幸好我们晚上开始。
Dimitri is careful to make everything as comfortable as possible for Jimmy. He even turns around the LCD alarm clock because he knows people are really sensitive to light when they're on ibogaine. Then he takes out about 20 capsules containing varying amounts of ibogaine. He leaves the pills on the desk and tries to figure out how much to give Jimmy.
迪米特里小心地让吉米尽可能舒服。他甚至把液晶闹钟转过去，因为他知道人们在服用伊博格碱时对光线非常敏感。然后他拿出大约20粒含有不同剂量伊博格碱的胶囊。他把药片留在桌子上，试图弄清楚给吉米吃多少。
All right. I'm going to do about 16. [WHISTLING] Hmm, that's too much. Hmm.
好吧。我大概要给16粒。[口哨声] 嗯，那太多了。嗯。
Can  you see what you're doing?
你看得见自己在做什么吗？
I'm going to give him a dose of like 16 milligrams per kilogram. I'm just trying to combine the pills so they add up to that. Yup, that's right. OK.
我要给他服用大约每公斤16毫克的剂量。我只是在试图组合药片，让它们相加达到那个量。是啊，没错。好的。
You ready, buddy?
你准备好了吗，伙计？
Yeah, I'm ready.
是的，我准备好了。
OK.
好的。
Jimmy strips down to his underpants and crawls into bed before taking the dose. His job is to lay there, as still as possible, in this dark room and let the drug take effect. Dimitri's job is to wait on the other side of the door in case anything goes wrong. After two hours, Dimitri goes in to check on his patient. Jimmy doesn't acknowledge we're there until Dimitri asks how he's doing. He opens his eyes and looks around. But just like a newborn baby, his eyes don't really focus on anything.
吉米只穿着内裤，在服用剂量前爬进床里。他的任务是躺在那里，尽可能静止，在这个黑暗的房间里，让药物起作用。迪米特里的任务是在门的那一边等待，以防出现什么问题。两个小时后，迪米特里进去查看他的病人。吉米没有承认我们在那里，直到迪米特里问他感觉如何。他睁开眼睛看着周围。但就像新生儿一样，他的眼睛并没有真正聚焦在任何东西上。
Oh, it's really intense.
噢，真的太强烈了。
It's really intense?
真的太强烈了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
OK. Did you throw up a little bit?
好的。你吐了一点吗？
Huh?
哈？
Did you throw up a little bit?
你吐了一点吗？
Yeah.
是的。
You're doing fine though, buddy. You're doing really good. Do you want me to get a towel for you?
你做得很好，伙计。你做得真的很好。你需要我给你拿条毛巾吗？
Huh?
哈？
You want a towel?
你需要毛巾吗？
No.
不用。
OK, buddy. OK.
好的，伙计。好的。
The treatment takes about 30 hours and is, at least for Dimitri and me, uneventful. We watch a lot of TV. Dimitri checks in on Jimmy and cleans him up when he throws up. Jimmy just lies there having visions, not sleeping, but not fully coherent either.
治疗大约需要30小时，至少对迪米特里和我来说，没什么大事。我们看了很多电视。迪米特里进去看望吉米，并在他呕吐时帮他清理。吉米只是躺在那里产生幻觉，没有睡觉，但也完全不清醒。
Dimitri seems worried when Jimmy's finished with the treatment. Jimmy's isn't euphoric the way people usually are. Instead, he's kind of depressed and agitated. And after chatting a little bit, Jimmy reveals that he'd been doing coke the night before.
治疗结束后，迪米特里显得很担心。吉米不像人们通常那样欣快。相反，他有点沮丧和激动。闲聊了一会儿后，吉米透露他前一天晚上吸了可卡因。
I was getting high the night before. Coke.
我前一天晚上吸得很high。可卡因。
Oh, you did coke the night before.
噢，你前一天晚上吸了可卡因。
Yeah. I was smoking crack.
是的。我在吸快克。
Oh, smoking crack. Oh, let me tell you something. Don't smoke crack the night before.
噢，吸快克。噢，让我告诉你一件事。不要在前一天晚上吸快克。
I actually prior to when you called me up, I was smoking crack. When you called me and asked me where I was.
在你给我打电话之前，我实际上在吸快克。当你给我打电话问我在哪儿的时候。
At 5:00 o'clock?
在5点钟？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Now remember that when we picked Jimmy up, he told Dimitri he'd been clean since Thursday, the day before the treatment.
记住，我们接吉米时，他告诉迪米特里他从星期四（治疗前一天）开始就戒了。
So did you smoke crack all night?
所以你整晚都在吸快克？
Yeah.
是的。
So you didn't get any sleep?
所以你一点觉都没睡？
No. I was smoking crack.
没有。我在吸快克。
So basically you haven't slept since Thursday morning. And it's Sunday evening.
所以基本上你从星期四早上起就没睡过。现在是星期天晚上。
Right, right.
对，对。
So like, yeah, so you kind of had that crack ibogaine combo a little bit, right?
所以，是啊，所以你有点像吸了快克加伊博格碱的组合，对吧？
Yeah. I was doing benzos and methadone too.
是的。我也在吃苯二氮卓类药物和美沙酮。
Oh, really. How long?
噢，真的吗。多久了？
For about two weeks.
大约两个星期。
Anything else? I mean right now it doesn't really matter. Just for my amusement.
还有别的吗？我的意思是现在其实不重要了。只是出于我的好奇。
No, no.
没有，没有。
You weren't like sniffing shoe polish or anything like that? No, no glue. OK. All right.
你没有在嗅鞋油之类的东西吗？没有，没有胶水。好的。好的。
Dimitri was joking. But later when I talked to him, he copped to the fact that mixing all those drugs was a really bad idea. Something horrible could have happened.
迪米特里是在开玩笑。但后来我和他谈话时，他承认混用所有那些药物是个非常糟糕的主意。可能会发生可怕的事情。
And so, the risk would be like heart attack?
所以，风险可能是心脏病发作？
I don't know. I don't know. To be honest with you, I don't know. Maybe I should know, but I don't.
我不知道。我不知道。老实说，我不知道。也许我应该知道，但我不知道。
When I went home, I called the doctor who does ibogaine treatments at a licensed clinic in Cancun, Mexico. He told me that because Jimmy had taken benzodiazepine, there was a serious risk of seizure and potentially death, which brings us back to Dimitri's constant dilemma. He knows he's doing a really risky job. He can't control everything. And the stakes are very high. And when I raise this with him, he suddenly seemed sad.
回家后，我给墨西哥坎昆一家持牌诊所进行伊博格碱治疗的医生打了电话。他告诉我，因为吉米服用过苯二氮卓类药物，有严重的癫痫发作甚至死亡风险，这又回到了迪米特里永恒的困境。他知道他正在做一份风险很高的工作。他无法控制一切。而且利害攸关。当我向他提出这一点时，他突然显得很悲伤。
I probably don't have a lot of business doing it in a certain sense. But there's nobody else doing it.
在某种意义上，我可能没什么资格做这个。但没有别人在做。
And that it seems is the heart of it. No one else is doing it. So far everything's worked out OK for Dimitri. No one has been killed or hurt on his watch. In fact, he feels he's helped many people. And he likes doing this work.
这似乎就是核心所在。没有别人在做。到目前为止，迪米特里一切都很顺利。在他看护下没有人死亡或受伤。事实上，他觉得他帮助了很多人。而且他喜欢做这份工作。
The actual work is basically touching people, cleaning people, nurturing people, holding people up, soothing their fears, being stern when they need some direction. And during the actual-- and being really patient and quiet. It's not about me.
实际的工作基本上是接触人、清理人、滋养人、扶持人、安抚他们的恐惧，在他们需要指引时严厉一些。在实际过程中——要非常有耐心和安静。这不是关于我的。
The job is to love these people, he says. But sometimes that's really hard. There are just so many addicts with so many problems.
这份工作就是去爱这些人，他说。但有时这真的很难。有太多的瘾君子，有太多的问题。
OK. This guy's got a probation officer. And he needs to do this, this, and this. But he doesn't have a house. And this other guy's homeless too. And she's got like all these abandonment issues. And then this one can't really get it, because to get off the psych meds would be too much. And on and on and on. All these people with really sad, hard lives. I think about like what am I really doing? How important is it? And I think about that a lot. I think I've said this many times. This is what I can do. OK. This little thing. This little thing.
好的。这家伙有个缓刑官。他需要做这个、这个和这个。但他没有房子。另外那个家伙也是无家可归。她有所有这些被遗弃的问题。还有这个，真的搞不懂，因为戒掉心理药物太困难了。没完没了。所有这些人都有非常悲惨、艰难的生活。我思考我到底在做什么？它有多重要？我经常想那个。我想我已经说过很多次了。这就是我能做的。好的。这件小事。这件小事。
Dimitri just hopes doing that one little thing is enough.
迪米特里只是希望做那件小事就足够了。
Lu Olkowski. She reported this story with Trey Kay.
卢·奥尔科夫斯基。她和特雷·凯报道了这个故事。
Act Three. If This Ark Is A Rockin', Don't Come A Knockin'.
第三幕。如果这艘方舟在摇晃，别去敲门。
The Bible is just one big sink or swim after another. God throwing people into some situation where they're supposed to figure it out and do the right thing. Like for instance, Noah and the flood. Jonathan Goldstein has today's lesson.
《圣经》就是一个又一个的成败故事。上帝把人扔进某种境地，让他们自己想办法做正确的事。比如，诺亚和洪水。乔纳森·戈德斯坦有今天的课程。
Contrary to what most people think, the years leading up to the great flood were actually quite joyful. The pre-flood generation saw that the random smitings, the slavery, and the back-breaking labor of the early days had left their forefathers bitter and hateful. And so they collectively resolved to live lives of greater ease. Work, they realized, was overrated.
与大多数人的想法相反，大洪水前的那些年其实相当快乐。洪水前的一代人看到早期的随机打击、奴役和背后的苦力劳动让他们的祖先变得痛苦和仇恨。所以他们一致决定过更轻松的生活。他们意识到，工作被高估了。
Two days of toil a week were plenty. In this way, they had time for hobbies. People drew pictures, played music, and danced. It was a golden age of art. And the pre-flood generation really felt like they were onto something.
每周工作两天就足够了。这样，他们就有时间进行爱好活动。人们画画、玩音乐、跳舞。那是艺术的黄金时代。洪水前的一代人真的觉得他们走在正轨上。
One man though felt that this whole business was ass-backwards and off track. His name was Noah. He was over 400 years old and was used to the work ethic of the good old days. Noah swore in his wrath that he for one would always remain old school and he would keep his children old school, by teaching them about the value of good, hard work.
然而，有一个人觉得这一切都是倒退且偏离轨道的。他的名字叫诺亚。他400多岁了，习惯了过去的美好时光的职业道德。诺亚愤怒地发誓，他自己将永远保持老派，他也会让他的孩子们保持老派，通过教导他们优秀、勤奋工作的价值。
Noah and his sons were contractors. They built huts for people. Officially, the company name was Noah and Son and Son and Son. Though in private, Noah referred to his outfit as Noah and his good for nothing dummies. He called his sons dummies at least 100 times a day.
诺亚和他的儿子们是承包商。他们为人们盖小屋。官方名称是“诺亚及其儿子儿子儿子公司”。虽然在私下里，诺亚称他的团队为“诺亚及其一无是处的假人”。他每天至少100次叫他的儿子们假人。
Noah knew he disciplined his boys with great ferocity. But he also knew it was necessary. During those dark, evil days, one had to teach one's children right from wrong. And if that involved the use of straps, riding crops, thick branches, throat punches, and leg locks, so be it. That was what a father had to do.
诺亚知道他以极大的凶猛管教他的儿子们。但他也知道这是必要的。在那些黑暗、邪恶的日子里，一个人必须教导子女是非对错。如果这涉及到皮带、马鞭、粗树枝、喉咙重击和锁腿，那就随它去吧。这就是一个父亲必须做的。
One day while yelling at his sons as they worked, Noah heard a voice. He could only hear it faintly, under his own words. At first he thought it was a whistling in his nose hairs. He pressed a finger to each side of his nose and shotgunned mucus onto the floor. But still, the ghostly voice below the surface of his own speech persisted.
有一天，当诺亚在他们工作时冲儿子们大喊大叫时，他听到一个声音。他只能隐约听到，在自己的话语声之下。起初他以为是鼻毛里的哨音。他用手指压在鼻子的两侧，把鼻涕射到地板上。但那种潜藏在他自己言语下的幽灵般的声音仍然存在。
When he stopped to try and hear it better, the little voice would cease. Noah started to speak once more. And once more he heard the tiny voice behind his own voice. It was mumbly and high pitched, and he could hardly hear it. He kept his mouth shut for the rest of the day, communicating his wishes to his sons through a hardy assortment of lashes, sucker punches, and head butts. He put down his wine jug and waited for sobriety to return, whereupon he would take a long walk with Brandy, his beloved poodle. He would talk freely. He would see if the little voice still lingered.
当他停下来想听得更清楚时，那个小声音就会停止。诺亚再次开始说话。他又一次听到了那个在他自己声音背后的小声音。它含糊不清且音调很高，他几乎听不清。他那一天的余下时间里都闭着嘴，通过各种鞭打、暗箭和头槌来传达他对儿子的愿望。他放下了酒壶，等待清醒回来，之后他会带着他心爱的贵宾犬布兰迪散步。他会自由地说话。他会看看那个小声音是否还在。
Several weeks went by, and the voice continued still. Eventually, Noah began to understand little bits here and there. Out in the woods, Noah would speak. I am talking. I am talking. Blah, blah, blah. My sons are dummies. Blah, blah, blah. I am listening, and I'm talking. Blah, blah, blah. And as he spoke, he could hear, "You must build an ark made of gopher wood. I will guide your hand to choose animals, which you will place within the ark. There is going to be a great flood. All will drown except you and yours, and the chosen animals."
几周过去了，声音依然持续。最终，诺亚开始理解零星的片段。在树林里，诺亚会说话。“我在说话。我在说话。巴拉巴拉。我儿子是假人。巴拉巴拉。我在听，我在说话。巴拉巴拉。”当他说话时，他能听到：“你必须用歌斐木造一艘方舟。我会引导你的手选择动物，你会把它们放在方舟里。将会有一场大洪水。除了你和你的家人，以及选择的动物，所有人都会淹死。”
"What is gopher wood?"
“什么是歌斐木？”
"It's this wood that gophers like."
“就是歌斐鼠喜欢的木头。”
"Can I enlist the help of the dummies to build the ark?"
“我可以招募那些假人来帮我造方舟吗？”
"No. You must do it yourself."
“不行。你必须自己做。”
"Why build an ark?"
“为什么要造方舟？”
"I shall bring a flood that will wipe out the world. The whole thing was a bad mistake, except for you. You I like."
“我将带来一场洪水，消灭这个世界。整个事情是一个巨大的错误，除了你。我喜欢你。”
"Who are you?"
“你是谁？”
"I'm the creator of the universe."
“我是宇宙的创造者。”
Noah decided to set the whole family down and tell them what God had in store. I was just talking with the Lord, said Noah. And you know what, he regrets having made his children too. And he says it just like this. I will blot them out.
诺亚决定让全家人坐下来告诉他们上帝的旨意。“我刚和主谈过，”诺亚说，“你知道吗，他后悔造了他们的孩子。他就是这样说的。我要涂抹他们。”
The brothers looked at each other. "What does that mean, blot them out?", asked his son Shem. You take your thumb and you smoosh 'em into the earth like lady bugs. He's going to drown the whole world with his tears of rage. And after everyone's dead, he's going to start fresh. And guess who he chose to spearhead the operation? That's right. Me. Also, you virginal dummies have to get married so we can reseed the earth. Enough waxing the nimrod. Clean your toga and get out there.
兄弟们面面相觑。“那是什么意思，涂抹他们？”他的儿子闪问道。“你用拇指像瓢虫一样把他们抹到地上。他要用愤怒的泪水淹没整个世界。在所有人都死后，他要重新开始。猜猜他选择了谁来负责这项行动？没错。我。还有，你们这些童贞的假人必须结婚，这样我们才能重新播种地球。别再磨洋工了。洗洗你们的托加长袍，出去干活。”
His father had had visions before. And so the prevailing opinion was that the old man was, once again, off his rocker. Of everyone, the family, the neighbors, the village at large, it was Noah's youngest son Ham who was the only one that sort of believed that his father might not be crazy. From what Ham had heard about God, he was a lot like their father. Tough, stubborn, and prone to yelling right in your face for pretty much no reason. To Ham, a flood didn't seem that out of the question. And God would have chosen his father, because his father felt just like he did. He hated his kids, and was going to teach them the meaning of righteousness by killing them dead.
他的父亲以前也曾有过幻觉。所以主流观点是，老人又疯了。在所有人中，家庭、邻居、整个村庄，诺亚最小的儿子哈姆是唯一一个相信他父亲可能没疯的人。从哈姆听到的关于上帝的消息来看，上帝很像他们的父亲。坚韧、固执，且毫无理由地冲到你脸上大喊大叫。对于哈姆来说，洪水似乎并非不可能。上帝选择了他的父亲，因为他的父亲和他的感觉一样。他讨厌他的孩子，要通过杀死他们来教会他们正义的含义。
Sometimes when his father was hard at work on his ark, Ham would sit off to the side and draw pictures of it. It incensed Noah. Are you sick in the head, Noah would exclaim. Why would anyone want to make stupid pictures? Can you eat them? Can you build a house with them? Can you use your precious art to diaper your loins? As far as Noah could see, Ham's artist friends did not contribute much to society. Still, Ham liked them. He spent much of his time with a woman artist named Lila. Recently, Lila had covered an apple tree in bear fur and replaced all the apples with dead snakes. She called it the tree of knowledge.
有时，当他的父亲在辛苦建造方舟时，哈姆会坐在旁边画方舟的图画。这激怒了诺亚。“你脑子有病吗？”诺亚会惊呼。“为什么有人想做愚蠢的画？你能吃它们吗？你能用它们盖房子吗？你能用你珍贵的艺术给你的腰部换尿布吗？”在诺亚看来，哈姆的艺术家朋友们对社会贡献不大。不过，哈姆喜欢他们。他把大部分时间都花在一个名叫莉拉的女艺术家身上。最近，莉拉用熊皮覆盖了一棵苹果树，并用死蛇取代了所有的苹果。她称之为知识之树。
Ham thought Lila's work was provocative. And he thought Lila herself was possessed of a strange blond-haired, weasel-like beauty. While sitting together one day sketching pictures of Noah as he worked, Ham turned to Lila and said, "If somehow the old man is right about this whole flood thing, I'd like you to come and ride out the flood with me." Lila considered Ham's offer. Then she took his hand.
哈姆认为莉拉的作品很有挑衅性。他认为莉拉本人拥有一种奇怪的、金发黄鼠狼般的美。有一天，当他们坐在一起画诺亚工作时的画时，哈姆转向莉拉说：“如果那个老头关于这场洪水的事说对了，我想让你和我一起度过洪水。”莉拉考虑了哈姆的提议。然后她握住了他的手。
When the ark was ready, Noah took to the task of gathering animals. After only one day of work, he already looked like hell. He appeared to be bleeding out of every pore in his body. He had two black eyes, three broken ribs, and his nose hung half off his face from a bobcat bite. So great was his pain, that after the very first day even Noah began to doubt whether he had actually heard the voice of God. "Is one obligated to trust the voice inside one's nose?" Noah asked himself. Maybe I am sick in the head. But what is there left for me? If I admit to that, it means the dancing dummies are right about the world and I am wrong. There is nothing left for me to do but to persist. And so he persisted.
当方舟准备好时，诺亚承担了收集动物的任务。仅仅工作了一天，他看起来就像从地狱来的一样。他看起来全身每个毛孔都在出血。他有两个黑眼圈，三根肋骨骨折，他的鼻子因为被山猫咬了一口而挂在脸上。他的痛苦如此巨大，以至于仅仅在第一天之后，连诺亚都开始怀疑他是否真的听到了上帝的声音。“一个人有义务相信鼻子里的声音吗？”诺亚问自己。也许我脑子有病。但还能剩下什么？如果我承认这一点，那就意味着那些跳舞的假人关于世界是对的，而我是错的。除了坚持下去，我别无选择。于是他坚持下去了。
As Noah hunted around for animals, he judged them. He wanted to try and bring only the most worthy animals aboard his ark. He would stop by a group of rabbits and figure out who was a hardworking rabbit and who was a lazy, stupid dummy. Judging the rabbits made him feel a bit like God. He liked that. As he walked away with the ones he had chosen for salvation, he would look back at their brethren and shake his head disapprovingly. Goodbye, you dead dummies. And that was that.
当诺亚到处搜寻动物时，他评判它们。他想尝试只把最值得的动物带上方舟。他会在一群兔子旁边停下来，弄清楚谁是勤劳的兔子，谁是懒惰、愚蠢的假人。评判兔子让他感觉有点像上帝。他喜欢那样。当他带着选中的动物离开去获救时，他会不赞同地回头看看他们的同类。“再见，你们这些死假人。”就是这样。
The flood started slowly. It did not seem biblical at all. The first day was nothing more than a drizzle really. Nothing to cause alarm. It continued like this for some time. We sure are getting an awful lot of rain for this time of year, people said. But eventually it got worse. The rain fell faster and heavier. Each drop fat with purpose and spite.
洪水开始得很缓慢。它看起来一点也不像圣经里描述的那样。第一天只不过是一场毛毛雨。没什么可担心的。就这样持续了一段时间。“今年的降雨量还真是多啊，”人们说。但最终情况变糟了。雨下得更快、更重。每一滴雨都充满了目的和恶意。
Ham stood looking at the ark with Lila at his side. His father was already on board. He'd begun to live in there several days earlier as the very first drops of water fell. Ham turned his head towards the sky and felt the drops of rain pock-mark his face. He imagined them all in the ark. He imagined the aardvarks, the orangutans, the smell, the claustrophobia, his father's constant screams and shouts. He imagined himself deciding at the very last minute to forego the ark entirely and take his chances with the flood.
哈姆站在旁边看着方舟，莉拉在他身边。他的父亲已经在船上了。在第一滴水落下时，他就在几天前住进去了。哈姆转向天空，感觉雨点敲打着他的脸。他想象他们都在方舟里。他想象食蚁兽、猩猩、气味、幽闭恐惧症、他父亲不断的尖叫和叫喊。他想象自己在最后一刻决定放弃方舟，干脆冒险面对洪水。
The sky began to hemorrhage. All at once, the drops became indistinguishable one from the other. The water poured down like all the heavens had become an inverted ocean. Ham opened his mouth to scream and caught a yap-full of water. The taste reminded him of this time when he was 10 and had almost drowned at the beach. In a panic, he grabbed Lila by the skin of her bicep and together, they ran up the plank and into the cold, echoey darkness of the ark.
天空开始崩裂。一下子，雨滴变得无法区分彼此。大雨倾盆而下，仿佛整个天空变成了一个倒置的海洋。哈姆张开嘴尖叫，结果嘴里灌满了水。这种味道让他想起10岁时在海滩差点淹死的那次。他惊慌失措地抓住莉拉二头肌的皮肤，他们一起跑上木板，跑进了方舟冰冷、回声荡漾的黑暗中。
The first hands he heard banging at the outside walls of the ark felt like nails pushing into his temples. Then there were more hands, pounding, punching, scratching. Then kicks and shrieking that even drowned out the sound of the rain. The worst was when Ham was able to make out individual voices. He could hear their neighbor [? Zebala ?] and her little daughter Ariel. They called his name. "Let them bang", said Noah. "God knows what he's doing."
他听到的第一个敲击方舟外壁的声音感觉就像钉子刺进他的太阳穴。然后有更多的手，敲击、重击、抓挠。然后是尖叫声，甚至盖过了雨声。最糟糕的是当哈姆能辨认出个别的声音时。他能听到他们的邻居 [？泽巴拉？] 和她的小女儿阿丽尔。她们喊他的名字。“让她们敲吧，”诺亚说，“上帝知道他在做什么。”
"You know, we can empty out the alligator cage to make room for a few more people", offered Ham. "The world can do without alligators."
“你知道，我们可以腾出鳄鱼笼子，为更多人腾出空间，”哈姆提议说。“世界没有鳄鱼也能转。”
"And disobey God? You dummy. And you try reopening that door. Do you have any idea what a pain in the ass we'd be in for? No thanks." Noah sat down and ate apples in the dark, waiting for his ark to rise above the world.
“而且违抗上帝？你这假人。你试着重新打开那扇门。你知道我们会陷入多大的麻烦吗？不了，谢谢。”诺亚坐下来，在黑暗中吃苹果，等待他的方舟升起在世界之上。
For 40 days and 40 nights, they rode the ark as the animals roared, whined, and screeched. Sometimes when things quieted down, Noah and his family pressed their ears against the walls to try and figure out where they were. Most often though, they just spent their time remembering. Ham thought back to the days he'd spent with his artist friends and some of the old crowd he ran with. There was Aloysius, who lived in a tree house and made big pots of bark soup for the hungry. And Gwendolyn, a young widow who kept her big fat baby in a sack on her back. And when she danced, you couldn't help but smile. He thought about every single person he had ever known, and how he would never see them again.
在40昼夜里，他们骑着方舟，听着动物们的咆哮、哀鸣和尖叫。有时当事情安静下来，诺亚和他的家人把耳朵贴在墙上，试图弄清楚他们在哪里。但大多数时候，他们只是花时间回忆。哈姆回想起他与艺术家朋友们度过的日子，还有一些他交往过的老人群。那里有阿洛伊修斯，他住在树屋里，为饥饿的人煮大锅的树皮汤。还有格温多林，一个年轻的寡妇，背着一个装着大胖婴儿的袋子。当她跳舞时，你忍不住会微笑。他想到他认识的每一个人，以及他再也见不到他们了。
Believing it might bring him some solace, Ham pulled out a stick of a sketching tool and some parchment, and went over to draw the puppies in their cages. He studied their faces. He tried to see what God and his father had seen in them, why they had chosen in these particular dogs over all the others. The two dogs paced about their cage. And as Ham watched them, the puppy that was slightly larger set upon the haunch of the other. And for no apparent reason, tore into it with nasty, purposeful bites. The smaller dog yelped, twisted its body over, and sank its teeth into the ear of its attacker. Flopped upon each other in this way, the puppies rolled across the floor.
相信这可能会给他带来一些安慰，哈姆拿出一根绘图工具和一些羊皮纸，去画笼子里的幼犬。他研究它们的脸。他试图看看上帝和他的父亲在它们身上看到了什么，为什么它们选择了这些狗而不是其他所有的狗。两只狗在它们的笼子里踱步。当哈姆看着它们时，那只稍微大一点的小狗扑向另一只的后腿。毫无缘由地，它用凶狠、有目的的咬伤撕咬它。较小的那只狗尖叫着，扭转身体，把牙齿沉进攻击者的耳朵里。就这样纠缠在一起，小狗们滚过地板。
Ham turned away and walked over to the giraffe cage. There he found the long-necked beasts eye-to-eye, each trying to step on the other's hooves. He looked over at the tiger cage, where the tigers were scraping at the walls to get at the bear cubs next door. And the bear cubs sat stock still, eyeing Ham with hunger. Ham left the cages and went looking for Lila. She was sitting on the floor, painting a flower onto a rock she held in her hand. He knelt down beside her, put his face in her hair, and waited for the rain to stop.
哈姆转过身，走向长颈鹿笼。在那里，他发现那些长颈的野兽眼对眼，每只都试图踩对方的蹄子。他看向老虎笼，那里的老虎正在抓挠墙壁，想去抓隔壁的小熊崽。小熊崽静静地坐着，用饥饿的眼神看着哈姆。哈姆离开了笼子，去寻找莉拉。她坐在地板上，在手里拿的一块石头上画着一朵花。他在她身边跪下，把脸埋进她的头发里，等待雨停。
Jonathan Goldstein. He's the host of the CBC radio program, Wire Tap.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦。他是CBC电台节目《Wire Tap》的主持人。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is always coming up and asking me, what is the point to all these radio shows that we do?
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他总是走过来问我，我们做的这些广播节目到底有什么意义？
Can you eat them? Can you build a house with them? Can you use your precious art to diaper your loins?
你能吃它们吗？你能用它们盖房子吗？你能用你珍贵的艺术给你的腰部换尿布吗？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。